des photos et messages audio qui depuis
plusieurs semaines inondent les réseaux
sociaux ils sont accompagnés de messages
écrits dont les auteurs prétendent avoir
identifié un groupe de braqueurs qui
sévit dans l'île
aujourd'hui l'un des jeunes hommes
apparaissant sur les clichés clame son
innocence il affirme ne rien avoir à
faire avec ces vols et s'émeut des
conséquences de telles dénonciations
publiques
moi je suis même pas conscients de ça je
suggérerais temps au tour jeu pour
continuer ma vie je fais mes affaires de
tous les jours et puis tu as des gens de
notre côté qui reçoivent des images
comme quoi je fais partie de complot je
suis avec les braqueurs donc c'est super
s'est vite et moi je moi j'étais pas
donc j'ai fait mes affaires
tranquillement et puis tu as des gens
qui sont de plus peut-être certains de
comploter sur moi en pensant que j'ai un
rapport avec le vol de la moto c'est pas
mon truc et je trouve que j'ai peut-être
j'ai eu des démêlés avec la justice plus
jeune j'ai eu des problèmes à justice
mais dans sa non tout est ce que ça peut
venir au poids pourquoi vous pourquoi
des photos de vous aucune idée je sais
pas avec un autre homme qui apparaît
aussi sur les réseaux sociaux
françois laurent s'est rendu à la police
des forces de l'ordre qui dénonce des
pratiques internet pas toujours à leur
avantage
quand la police en inquiéter sous ces
photos là c'est une perte de temps
hier vous en avez 3 3 jeunes qui ont été
accusés qui sont venus au commissariat
pour dire on ne nous voit là on vient
nous et nous ont pas ce qu'on a dit que
c'est nous qui sommes les voleurs et
bien et c'est nous qui sommes les
braqueurs sauf que avec des preuves à
l'appui qu'il n'était pas là on disait
donc on est où là
la police a perdu du temps ça fait trois
quatre et collègues enquêteurs qui sont
mobilisés à vendre ses pets à vérifier
les dires de ces jeunes là parce qu on
les accusait vous avez vu aucune affiche
de recherche de policiers aucun avis de
recherche de gendarmes et aucun avis de
recherche du coût de leur public si ce
sont pas des voleurs vous vous rendez
compte si par exemple quelques énervé
parce qu'on avait les sa voiture et +17
wallace et les volets voit ces trois
jeunes on sent qu'on par hasard en train
de boire une bière ou un café soit il
fonce dans le tas avec sa voiture sur la
chaussée sont ni volver et bing bang et
eu trois personnes rappelées par des
formes et des photos sur le net
aucun nos poissons avec en rien du tout
une utilisation des réseaux sociaux de
plus en plus courante est banal pouvant
faire l'objet de plaintes pour
diffamation